ben shapiro is the editor-in-chief of
daily wired.com cinema Cawood columnist
and the host of the ben shapiro show he
joins us right now from the West Coast
Ben good morning to you
morning I'm sure you've been watching
it's a feeding frenzy on some of the
other channels regarding what the
President may or may not have said
yesterday when he was in that dacha deal
and it was reported by The Washington
Post initially that he said that word
we're not going to use on this program
referring to certain countries but the
president then tweeted this out about an
hour ago he said the language used by me
at the daka meeting was tough but this
was not the language used what was
really tough was the outlandish proposal
made a big setback for daca alright so
we've set the table where would you like
to start well I mean I think that we can
start with the denial it's unclear you
know whether this was said or not now
the president has denied it I would have
preferred that if he's going to deny he
did it right away obviously rather than
waiting 15 hours to do so because
obviously things sort of blew up in the
meantime
as far as the the comments that he's
accused of saying they're really two
comments that he made right there's the
one where he said why are we letting all
these people from bleep whole countries
into the country and then he said
something about all these Haitians
they should be deported or something
something along those little second
accusation yeah to get them out so
something like that that second
accusation seems less well substantiated
than the first in terms of the sourcing
that the Washington Post used and it's
the second accusation that I think is is
worse in a lot of ways the first comment
that the there are there there are a lot
of reasons people seem offended this
morning one is the idea that Trump said
some countries are bleep holes to be
fair to the president some countries are
really crappy right in Sudan North Korea
Haiti is not a great place to live it
has a life expectancy of 63 years in an
average annual GDP per capita of like
730 bucks it's not a great place to live
so and and the cursing is it something
that we love nobody said it behind
closed doors I'm like Joe Biden who
actually said on a live mic President
Obama's the Obamacare deal was a big
effing deal right so the vulgarity I
find the media is jumping up and down
over that a little bit extreme
considering that they're happy to
actually say the word that none of us
are saying on air right now over and
over on other networks the the second
question is whether he's actually saying
that people
from bad countries should not come to
the United States because there's some
for some nefarious reason now there are
two reasons why you could say the people
from those countries shouldn't come over
or shouldn't be privileged in for
example the diversity visa lottery
program the first reason is not actually
bigoted right that's the idea that
depending on the country that you are
from you may not be as well able to
assimilate and that's not a black-white
thing if you're from Russia maybe you're
not as able to assimilate easily as if
you're from Great Britain and in this
case the president's choices of
countries are really unfortunate because
when he contrast Haiti and Norway it
gives people the ability to say well
he's meeting black and white when really
all that he means is maybe assimilation
rates aren't the same from different
countries which Norway was here 48 hours
ago the president with that was on the
forefront of his mind number one and
number two per capita income is through
the roof so they they say that in terms
of terms of quality of living but people
saw it at black and white right exactly
I think that's correct
the second way of reading it is the the
way which improves bigotry in the
president I think it requires a little
bit of a jump and that's the idea the
president was saying we don't want
people from these companies bleep whole
countries because they're bleep whole
people and I think that the media are
taking it that way again I think that
requires a little bit of a leap I'm not
sure that that's exactly what the
president was saying and without his
exact warning and without any context as
to what he was saying right you know I
think that how you view this is a
Rorschach test on how you view the
president if you want him to be seen as
a bigot if you think he's a bigot
already you're gonna jump to he's a
bigot from these comments right if you
don't think he's a bigot you're gonna
say that's not what he meant by this at
all now would I prefer it not said this
of course but that's true about like
half the stuff the president says for
myself that's very Ben this is Rachel
capital stuffy talking to you
I agreed listen I think some of our best
immigrants have come from crappy
governments and country so I'm you know
a little bit perplexed by that hoping he
didn't actually say that that said you
know when is he gonna stop trusting the
Democrats I mean we all say irreverent
things you know on PC things when we
think we're in a private setting but
gosh I mean he probably should know by
now that the Democrats are out for blood
in no question that if you're going to
say stuff like it's it's not
particularly smart to say it in front of
people who are not your political allies
shouldn't say stuff like this to begin
with as you mentioned and you're exactly
right one of the arguments in favor of
bringing in people from bad
traces that they know what they're
leaving right now first immigrants are
coming from places that are quite
terrible including my great-grandparents
when they came over and I think pretty
much everybody in the country's
great-grandparents came over for the
summer one similar they considered bad
including the pilgrims so the idea that
that you know that that line works but
but you're right that you know the
president I swear if the man could just
stay off Twitter and watch his mouth he
would rise five points in the approval
ratings almost immediately and the proof
of this is that every time he goes out
of the country and he doesn't have
access to Twitter and he doesn't
actually speak to the press he's not
talking to Democrats his approval
ratings rise five to ten but he does
actually very good in these settings in
these international settings as well
sure all right so let's talk about Nancy
Pelosi if we can because she's getting a
total pass here about what she says
about the money that so-called average
people are making and getting increases
off this economic plan and how she
described the meeting that was held
without her first off when we she was
told that thousand dollar bonuses were
being handed out in places like Walmart
we're raising up their minimum wage this
was her reaction in terms of the bonus
that corporate America received versus
the crumbs that they are giving to
workers to kind of put the schmooze on
is so pathetic hmm crumbs to put the
schmooze on could you please you live in
California can you explain what she's
talking about no I know I have no idea
what she's talking about you know as a
Jewish person who uses the word schmooze
pretty regularly you don't put the
schmooze on that's that's not actually a
thing and beyond that you know when when
Nancy Pelosi says that people who are
low income and getting raises from from
because of the president's tax cuts and
the Republican tax cuts when she says
that that doesn't mean anything for
those people and that's pretty
derogatory toward people who she's
supposed to be courting I mean I think
the whole problem for the Democrats they
didn't win a lot of blue-collar votes in
places like Ohio Pennsylvania Wisconsin
and now they're going around saying that
if you get a thousand bucks back from
your employer you get a raise from your
employers doesn't mean anything because
it's not enough money maybe she should
stop hanging out in Marin County and
start hanging out and in rural I know
the second thing we wanted to bring up
is which he said about the meeting that
was taking place without her the highest
mark the high
franking person there was Steny Hoyer
Nancy Pelosi came out and said what do
you mean that meeting with a bunch of
white guys you have five white guys
maybe they should open up some type of
the other stand I don't even know what
that means but Steny Hoyer was offended
I mean it's it's that in the number one
do people have to worry about her
stability well I mean yeah I'm not sure
that Nancy Pelosi has been all there for
a while but I'm not gonna play our
church a psychiatrist I think the voters
are gonna have to decide whether or not
they they want Nancy Pelosi representing
them and in San Francisco apparently
they do but but Nancy Pelosi you know
doing this this routine about insert you
know intersectionality with regard to
congressional leadership well
the negotiations definitely would have
gone differently if Nancy Pelosi were
there she's gonna have to explain why
she would have negotiated any
differently than Stanny Hoyer whose her
deputy and I'm just confused is she a
she on a different page than standing or
did Trump not invite her because she's a
woman is that the implication because
that seems pretty pretty stupid actually
well maybe president Trump should put
the schmooze on her then next time one
other thing we wanted to ask you about
and apparently there is a newspaper
report that the Obama administration
tipped off Iranian terrorists that
Israel planned to assassinate him just
because they wanted to make sure the
Iran nuke deal a Barack Obama legacy
item went through well it wouldn't be
the most surprising story this comes
from Haaretz which is an Israeli
newspaper that's usually well sourced
their reporting at secondhand based on
another report Ben Rhodes the former
national security adviser essentially to
President Obama apparently quasi denied
it on Twitter but it wouldn't be a
particularly surprise for the Obama
administration to be making provision
for Iranian terrorists considering
there's an entire political report from
Europe all about how they had done so
for Hezbollah because they wanted to pay
off the Iranian regime in order so they
could ram through this nuclear deal so
your hackles always have to be up your
your your kind of antenna have to be up
whenever there's a story about the Obama
administration trying to bend over
backwards to help evil people on behalf
of that Iran nuclear deal they were
lying the American people continuously
about it of course then if this is true
this is the most powerful person in the
Iranian Revolutionary Guard who is
responsible really tangentially for many
American deaths this that would be you
talk about a foreign policy disaster
that needs to be investigated soleimani
this guy we basically we told him he's
not allowed to leave the country yet he
turned up in Russia so this this would
be something extraordinary if this is
proven correct it definitely would be a
bombshell and one of the things that's
amazing is Tommy Vietor who of course
used to be a member of the Obama
administration apparently not when this
this story was broken he came out and he
said well why exactly is everybody so
exercised it's not like this guy
soleimani was like Osama bin Laden or
something that demonstrates the gap in
understanding about terrorism that the
Obama administration evidence nearly
every day in office absolutely all right
I joined us today from the West Coast
band thanks for getting up early I have
a great weekend thank you